good afternoon my name is Greg sterling
as Dean of Yale Divinity School and on
behalf of Yale University and the three
schools of divinity forestry and
environmental studies and management it
is my pleasure to welcome you and those
watching via Yale livestream to a
conversation with two of the most
socially and environmentally responsible
entrepreneurs of our generation this
event is co-sponsored by the Divinity
School and Yale Center for business and
the environment it is the first
installment of the business and the
environment Center's 2012-2013
sustainability leaders speaker series
which is sponsored by General Electric
we're deeply grateful for our
partnership with the center I want to
especially recognize the director the
program director of the center steward
DQ for his assistance and to the two
Dean's of those schools to Ted and Sir
Peter both for their collaboration along
with our corporate sponsor as a Dean it
is a particular matter of pride to be
able to recognize alumni this afternoon
it is my special privilege to introduce
our moderator who is one of our alums
Bob Massey after attending Princeton
University Bob came to Yale Divinity
School graduated in 1982 thirty years
ago served for two years as an ordained
Episcopalian priest in New York City and
then had the unusual experience of
attending Harvard Business School as a
doctoral student as an ordained minister
an interesting combination of
environments after finishing his
doctorate he joined the faculty at
Harvard Divinity School where he wrote
loosing the bonds the United States and
South Africa
the apart eight years a book that won
the 1998 Lionel Gelber prize for the
best book on international relations and
to this day is still considered by many
to be the definitive history of the
anti-apartheid and divestment movement I
remember that because I was a student in
Berkeley in that era after serving on
the faculty at Harvard he elected to
pursue for seven years he elected to
pursue a number of different careers
including either initiating or leading
three of the world's most influential
sustainability organization series the
largest coalition of investors and
environmental groups in the u.s. the
Global Reporting Initiative which has
become the global standard for corporate
disclosure on sustainability and the
investor network on climate risk which
has brought together more than a hundred
institutional investors with ten
trillion dollars in assets to press
companies to respond to the threat posed
by climate change he never left the
Academy completely and I have to tell
you in this venue that he returned to
Harvard where he spent two years as a
visiting scholar at Harvard Law School
focusing on issues of corporate
governance he recently published a song
in the night a memoir of resilience
released by Doubleday and he is
currently the president of the New
Economics Institute a think tank based
in Boston which is the leading
organization for the new economy
movement I can think of no one better
suited to moderate today's program than
one of our own
please join me in welcoming Bob masse
back to Yale who will introduce our two
principal conversant and the topic Bob
thank you very much Dean I I must admit
that was a very long and full
introduction thank you for that detail
it's tiny bit embarrassing because I did
not prepare a similarly long
introduction for our two speakers I was
operating under the assumption that they
were so well known for what they're
doing that they that we were in the
position of two people who need no
introduction or very little introduction
these are two men who have been
visionaries in the creation of a
particularly remarkable company
Patagonia they tell part of that story
in this extraordinary book that they
have just put out thee which I hope you
will all get the chance to read the
responsible company and it is a story of
creativity invention passion reinvention
and self-discovery now I'll tell you the
the genre of business leader who has had
some success who then writes up his or
her experience is a relatively popular
one and there are a lot of I've probably
read 40 or 50 such books in my career
and they all talk about lessons that
they've learned and they talk about how
unlikely their success was but I have to
tell you that this book is really
extraordinary in this category because
of its clarity its honesty its
practicality and it's powerful powerful
message about what they learned and what
they believe all of us need to learn to
advance the new economy as we face new
challenges and Planetary limits now
before I launch into my first question I
just would like to mention how I think
this will work I'm going to get the
conversation going with probably about
four questions and when I've concluded
those questions I invite you to come to
these microphones and you can alternate
Walternate and calling on you
I do want to remind you that it's very
important that your statement include a
question and that and I will look at you
skeptically if that seems like it's not
going to happen we also have people who
are watching us from I hope anyway
around the world certainly around the
internet and we are going to be taking
some questions from our social media
team over here with red cards and when
they wave at me now you're just out of
my line of sight so you may have to
really hop up and down to get my
attention but I will do my best to look
over there and we will ask some
questions that come from the internet
now I knew this was an extraordinary
book from the very first paragraph which
I'd like to read to you to get us
rolling here it is a very in in the
history of business writing this is a
really remarkable way to start a book we
are all still in the earliest stages of
learning how what we do for a living
both threatens nature and fails to meet
our deepest human needs the
impoverishment of our world and the
devaluing of the priceless undermine our
physical and economic well-being yet the
depth and breadth of technological
innovation of the past few decades shows
that we have not lost our most useful
gifts humans are ingenious adaptive and
clever we also have moral capacity
compassion for life and an appetite for
justice we now need to more fully engage
these gifts to make economic life more
socially just and environmentally
responsible and less destructive to
nature and the Commons that sustain us
pretty powerful opening words so I'm
gonna start with just a very basic
question what was your purpose in
writing this book and to whom did you
most want to address it
you know take that yeah
first of all Robert with your background
in economics and religion you should be
working for the Vatican Bank and the
Pope I'll bring that up with the power
well I wrote a book before called that
might people go surfing and it was
basically a book for my own employees to
explain to him why we were doing what we
were doing and why we were breaking the
rules of business and and so that that
was the real purpose of it and it's
become you know much more widespread
than I ever dreamed it's in was it 19
languages or something that's can't
remember now it's been used as a lot of
universities and schools but I saw a
need for a how-to book because we had so
many companies coming to us and saying
first of all coming to see if we're real
or is this just green marketing and they
wanted to do a lot of the things that
we're doing and I originally got the
idea from organization in Napa Valley
called Napa green which is one of the
most effective grassroots organizations
ever heard of it's a bunch of housewives
that put together a Xerox three-page
list of things that a vineyard can do to
become more sustainable and under energy
there's all these checklists of things
they can do under water uses and so if
if a vineyard checks off a certain
number of those then they can be
certified as a NAPA Green vineyard and
you know there's no vineyard that can do
even 50% of them
but it makes you aware of all the things
that you're not doing and this is all
volunteer this is a has nothing to do
with government there's no money
changing hands and what they and almost
every vineyard is trying to sign up
after they do the vineyards then they
want to do the restaurants and the
businesses after they do that they want
to do the houses in other words they're
trying to green an entire ecosystem from
the ground up which is you know as you
know change doesn't come from the top as
we all know comes from the bottom and
it's the most effective organization
I've seen and we wanted to do the same
thing with a book I thought about
upgrading my let my people go surfing
book but it's because it's I don't know
five or six years old or something but
Vincent had a better idea which is to do
a separate book and I feel like the most
important part of the book is the
checklist in the back which we have all
the different things you can do to
become a more society where it's
sustainable vincent yeah i think i think
i came at it from a little different
angle
i've been with the company from the
start but i'm vocationally a writer and
i was seeing that i was kind of coming
to the toward the end of my time at
Patagonia and i thought how do I kind of
organize what I think about this place
how do I I also was very curious about
how the culture could survive from a
very small company was like 10 15
employees and about 200,000 a year when
I started and now it's 2,000 employees
and about 600 million and I wanted to
kind of figure out for myself what
company was about and it's as a writer
the way you do that is to write it down
so and and I also wanted to leave
something for the people who work for me
that could then be passed down as a kind
of a supplement to let my people go
surfing so we got together and I think
with it actually the combination of the
trying to figure out what this company
is about with the checklist is really
strong because the checklist makes it
much more concrete it makes it we were
talking about this earlier I don't know
if you've read the the profile of Obama
and Vanity Fair but there's a statement
at some point saying that the
controversy machine is a lot bigger than
the reality machine and I think it's
very important for people doing this
work to bring a sense of reality about
what responsible practices are and what
the danger to the environment is what
the danger is to to our social systems
are as well and the checklist I think
brings it home in a way that a memoir or
an argument for what we're doing doesn't
when I was in business school one of the
things that surprised me because that
came there as a minister full of ideas
about justice and theories and so forth
was that Business School students in
general were extremely focused on
practicality on getting things done now
they didn't always think about the
bigger picture but present them with a
specific problem and they were
astonishing and their creativity and I
do want to say that almost half of this
book is made up of these very detailed
checklists which I think anyone
interested in this should look at
because lists have the ability to
stimulate thinking and you know
interesting for for the schools that
Yale to look through this and say well
some things may not apply but other
things might very much apply so that's
one of the things I wanted I should have
mentioned at the beginning I want to ask
now about sort of where we are in the
United States I was just talking to my
friend Steve Pearson who's here on the
yield
a school advisory board and he commented
that we seem to be in a period of
tremendous ferment on the one hand
there's a lot of discontent there people
who are unhappy with the inequality with
the environmental problems limits that
we are bumping up against on the other
hand there seems to be some real
learning going on and a lot of
creativity we see that in a new
economics Institute and we see that in
various regions and we see that in books
like this so my question is kind of a
big question but you address it in
several different places in this book is
how do you think our economy needs to
change and businesses need to change to
meet the needs for greater social
justice more meaningful work and
planetary survival well I go back to
that book small is beautiful which has a
lot of truth in it if you follow what
nature has to tell us
nature loves diversity it hates
monoculture it's an accumulation of any
thing in one place it's always trying to
spread everything out and if you look at
what humans try to do we try to collect
everything together we want to
centralize everything and yet you look
at the British Empire you look at the
Soviet Union you look at Yugoslavia you
look at you know we tried to do
nation-states in Africa that makes no
sense at all in fact I'd say the United
States is far too big a country it
should be broken up I mean I personally
don't want you know the senators from
Alabama telling me what to do
and they don't want senators from
California telling them what to do we
should and the best we're accomplishing
with government is cutting the baby in
half and compromise doesn't solve the
problem it just you know either there's
a right way or a wrong way and the
middle ground is not doesn't get us
anywhere and you know California's the
ninth largest economy in a world it
should be a sown country as far as I'm
concerned so I think for me a lot of the
problems in society are not going to be
solved with more technology technology
just destroys jobs it's a it's going to
be solved I think by going back to some
of the lessons we learned a long time
ago which you know if you want to employ
people the only way I can think of is go
back to labor intensive agriculture I
mean personally if if I was looking for
a job hell on earth would be staring at
a computer all day long I'd much rather
be picking fruit or picking grapes and
Provence that'd be even better but I
think we have we have to get away from
this gigantism we have to get away from
endless growth you know it's it's
corporations public corporations that
are fueling this endless growth they
have to grow 15 percent every year
otherwise you know the stock price goes
down and then the CEO and the upper
management can't retire to their golf
courses and it's absolutely wrong
and so anyway that's that's my own take
on it
I think they we have to decouple the
idea of economic growth from prosperity
in some way and certainly for material
use I think one of the things that when
you talk about the Contra ghin sort of
the controversy machine getting larger
than then then what we perceive reality
to be nobody really understands here we
don't have much manufacturing this
country anymore
and and nobody really understands the
complexity of the supply chain and the
immensity of it behind everything that's
made one of the things we've started to
do is to try to talk about that in our
own
clothing about how much in a single polo
shirt how much water is used to grow the
cotton how much a single polo shirt will
generate several times its own weight
and waste several times its own weight
and carbon emissions a wedding ring
generates 20 tons of mine waste so that
everything that's made has an economic
cost and often a social cost and I think
until we start to understand that and
decouple the idea of economic health
prosperity from increased use of
material goods we're going to continue
to be in the kind of trouble we are now
and it will accelerate there's a great
earnest Hemmingway line about in Sun
Also Rises how do how did you go
bankrupt it's one character asked
another he says in two ways
gradually than all of a sudden and I
think that that's the kind of bankruptcy
that our that our system faces I'd like
to continue on that a little bit first
of all I gone I did meet before and and
Vincent Knight I did not ask him to
mention EF Schumacher but if Schumacher
and small is beautiful is the prior
organization for the New Economics
Institute that grew and renamed itself
so we actually are the custodians of the
EF Schumacher books and materials out in
our library and great barrington and we
puzzle over this and feel that and I
want to invite everyone in the audience
to start thinking about this because
this question of how we're going to
continue to provide prosperity and
well-being for billions of people on the
planet without hitting at either high
speed or low speed the limits of the
planetary limits that have been set for
us in fact many limits that we're
already exceeding so if I could just
come back to that and go a little bit
more deeply you talk about meaningful
work at a living wage prosperity and
community
this is a central question especially in
the developing world where there's not
enough work and there's not enough
prosperity how can we make progress in
this area when we're simultaneously
being confronted with the absolutely
rock-hard planetary limits that we're
going to hit whether it's sooner whether
it's a little later but that
scientifically we know are certain well
I think this there's another old quote
that you think it's from Jefferson the
genius is the capacity to hold to equal
and opposite ideas in the head at the
same time and I think pretty shortly
we're all going to be geniuses because
we're going to have to I mean even if if
we if evil and I make arguments against
for decoupling growth from from from the
idea of prosperity even and the fact is
in the short run run it's horribly it's
horrible for the number of people who
are underemployed right now and who will
continue to be without some kind of
growth to the economy so I think we're
gonna have to take a long term and a
short term view we're also going to have
to take the kind of first world in a
developing world points of view into
account and I think when you're talking
about the economy there is the issue of
doing more things on a small scale and
doing them better like organic farming
which is much healthier for the planet
and possibly not for people but it
tastes better than industrial farming
but there's also the question of
industrial scale and changing some of
those processes so in the book I talked
about or we both talked about the the
work we've done with a sustainable
apparel coalition which is to join
together with a large consortium of
other companies who are responsible
we're almost up to about 70 members
where the goal is to get people who are
responsible for about half of the
apparel and footwear made in the world
established standards for different
kinds of standards for social justice
economic or and environmental
improvements and what that would do is
to change the way those things are made
and when you change industrial processes
on a huge scale you can make huge
improvements so even though we might
make the argument that in the long run
small is beautiful you also need to work
on the very dirty practices of the brown
economy right now and to change them and
to get groups of people together to
change them you know well know whenever
I'm confronted with a business problem
the answer has always increased the
quality always whether I mean I don't
care what the problem is and I think the
answer to this is more labor intensive
work whether it's organic farming I mean
John Jevons at ecology Action Center in
California has proven that you can get
more vegetables per acre with labor
intensive bio agriculture then you can
with this so-called Green Revolution
which is the Green Revolution has
produced a lot of food in a short period
of time but at the expense of destroying
millions and millions of acres of
topsoil and and that employs people in
meaningful work and I you know least
I've heard it said that man is the only
animal that doesn't learn from nature
from history we don't learn from history
we keep repeating the same problems but
there are some lessons in the past that
are really important and I've seen it
over and over again in my 73 years that
by simplifying your life looking for
simple solutions rather than complex
solutions to problems
to work really well in fact give an
example it I'm a fly fisherman I do a
lot of it lately I've been fishing with
a with a pole and no real with the 20
foot line tied on the end I've been
fishing in a style that goes back to the
15th century all the way back to the
first book ever written about fishing by
Dame Julianne burners and I go out with
some of the best fly fisherman in the
world at the end of the day they'll
catch six or eight fish
I'll catch 50 and I mean I could go on
about this for a long time but more and
more I realized that the answer to a lot
of the world's problems is simplicity
and quality go ahead thing I would add
is Bill McKibben talked in one of his
books about the higher yields of organic
farming but he also talked he said that
what it took was a lot more knowledge of
the land
you really have to walk your fields you
really have to know what you're doing
and I think that that's going to be
critical for all for all businesses for
the next 10 or 15 years because
everything is going to change so much
and so often that everybody in order to
have a company that thrives and to
employ other people is going to know I'm
awful lot more about their business than
they do now the same thing applies to
conventional businesses as to farming
the
the industrial farming is dumb it's
large-scale it's unsustainable and it
takes more intelligence to do it on a
smaller scale but when you when you know
your land then you can also adapt to new
threats and to new conditions or to new
opportunities a lot better than you can
if you're entirely dependent on very
simple dumb big systems so I'd like to
ask you a question that we talked about
briefly and you said people often beat
around the bush and you encouraged me
not to so I'm going to ask this you
operate in a very complex environment
you have to meet the expectations from
customers suppliers competitors
communities government regulators and
all different kinds of people all
expecting you and asking you to do
things now some people have pointed out
that because your company is privately
held you are able to do things that
avoid the quarterly pressures of
financial disclosure and financial
performance and that allows you of
flexibility and the ability to make
longer-term decisions on the other hand
there's a well-established literature
that says to be a publicly traded
company allows for a kind of
accountability for management that
sometimes doesn't exist when you are a
privately held company so my question is
how would you say your governance
structure over the years over 40 years
has affected Patagonia's decisions its
mission and its strategy and are you in
some way recommending that we should
have more privately held companies in
order to grant them the freedom from the
pressures that that publicly held
companies sometimes face just a quick
just a quick statement there are so many
more privately held companies in public
publicly held companies are large but
they're only four thousand of them in
the United States down from 7,000 a few
years ago so
it's a it's a very I'll just let you
could I also interject something you
told me something just before that I
didn't know and maybe it has bearing on
this which is that you're also a B
corporation and perhaps you'd like to
explain what a B corporation is and how
that fits with the question of being a
privately-held yeah well I mean a few
years ago when anyway the descendant of
Henry Ford was running Ford Motor
Company Bill Ford Bill Ford yeah he was
being touted as an environmentalist and
environmentalists we're asking well why
did why do you make SUVs you know
they're gas guzzlers they roll over
every chance they get
he said well we'll stop making them when
their customer tells us to you know
thinking that he's you know really
responsive to his customers and
everything but his but it was Henry Ford
that said the customer didn't want me to
make an automobile they wanted me to
make a faster horse and if you wait for
the customer tells you what to do you're
too late so I actually have you know way
more power as owner of Patagonia than a
CEO of a large public company who his
hands are tied by the stockholders you
know if if they give $100 to Planned
Parenthood they're gonna have all these
people you know bang in their tennis
shoes at the stockholder meeting and
complaining and you know I can basically
do what I want so it's given us you know
when we switched over from industrially
grown cotton to organically grown that
decision to do that as a public company
would have been an unconscionable
because nobody else was doing it a few
companies had tried it and
that stopped because it was unsuccessful
there was no organic cotton in the
country and it was a big risk we were
risking 25 percent of our sales on an
unproven thing and I just said I'm
giving the company 18 months to do it
and if we don't do it we're never gonna
make another piece of cotton again it's
like to mention in the with a Divinity
School hosting that we had to pray for
rain in the San Joaquin Valley our
cotton contracts came through well you
know we can take the risk that a public
company can and I you know I well first
of all you know how many people really
knew what was going on in Enron publicly
traded company you have no idea when
you're buying stock and some of these
corporations you have no idea what's
going on there and you get you know the
big financial reporting is I mean you
get two sets of books you get they show
a profit every quarter as a business you
cannot show a profit every quarter I
don't care who you are
it's it's just but that's what happens
the other no I'm sorry yeah I mean I'm
down on public corporations and down on
the stock market I have nothing to do
with it I have no stocks my retirement
fund is tied up in second growth forests
in the Pacific Northwest so no matter
what the stock market does my trees grow
ten percent a year
I think one of the the the problem of
accounting financial accounting is the
sole legal measurement of corporate
success is kind of paralleled with using
GDP as the sole measure of economic
success for a country it doesn't really
reveal the total health of the company
it just reveals that you know kind of
what the artfulness of the accountants
and and some more indications of the
basic health of the financial health but
not the social health or the
environmental health of the company I'd
like to come back to that question and a
little bit after we open it up I'm asked
one more question and so please be
prepared with your own questions and if
you in fact even like to start lining up
now at either one of these microphones
that would be great one of the things
that and this reminds me from the I
found the story about cotton really
quite remarkable and then you say under
the chapter what we do for a living you
talk about that there were a handful of
moments that stunned us into
consciousness I'd be really interested
and I think the audience would be
interested in hearing more about that
well I think I've I have a story about
our Boston store we opened this door in
Boston there's an old building and we
retrofitted it fixed it up and opened it
in the springtime brought in a lot of
sportswear because it was all is in the
spring and within three days our
employees are complaining about getting
headaches so we closed the store brought
in an environmental engineer and he said
oh says you're poisoning your employees
okay
says yeah the problem is you got the
ventilation system is recycling the same
air not bringing any outside air and
it's it's faulty so most companies would
have just said fix the ventilation
system I don't want to hear about the
poisoning but I wanted to hear about the
poisoning and turned out
that I was formaldehyde poisoning which
is put on all cotton clothing that is
sanfur eyes shrink resistant wrinkle
resistant it's a resin put on and it
just in the last few months the EPA has
acknowledged that it is very very toxic
it's still being used and it's and it's
in fact hair salons
use it to straighten hair they put it
right on your head
and I said yeah we I had no idea this
was happening and how do we get rid of
formaldehyde and I had no idea because
all we did was call a fabric supplier
and he'd come by with books on fabrics
and say oh yeah I like this sure ting
you know give me ten thousand yards of
this and we had no idea how cloth is
finished we had no idea which fibers are
more toxic whether should we be making
clothing out of polyester which is made
from petroleum or should we be making it
out of 100% pure cotton but industrially
grown we had no idea so that's that was
the aha moment that we started
questioning what we were doing because
we were doing business just like
everybody else
and once you start asking those
questions then you're for us we're
committed to doing something about it
once we find out that we're using toxic
dyes then we stop using toxic dyes and
and and so it goes all the way down to
the supply chain now that you know like
Vincent said we calculate how much water
we use in a t-shirt well it's not just
water water isn't just water it makes a
big difference whether the water comes
from the sky and rain whether it comes
from a gigantic dam that's been put in
that's destroyed a lot of people's lives
and and very damaging or
is it depleting enough up an aquifer
that uses that's millions of years old
the fossil water that's not being
replenished so now you know we're faced
with ok where are we going to grow our
cotton because we want to grow it we
want to buy cotton from areas where it
rains and but then that's that adds more
problems because there's more bugs and
now wet humid climate and I mean living
an examined life and business is a pain
in the ass
that's a quote but that's what we have
to do ok please hi my name is Sarah
Smith I'm a joint degree student with
the School of Management in the School
of Forestry here and I wanted to ask you
mentioned narrowness of using GDP as a
economic measure of success and
financial accounting for companies so
what are some alternative majors I can
try and speak up is that better ok I'll
try and speak slowly thank you ok what
are some alternative indicators of
success that Patagonia has is using and
inside the organization how did you come
up with those and how are they
integrated into the company internal
indicators you know if you ask me what
our profits were last year or what
they're gonna be this year I have no
idea I'm I I'm I own this business to
basically put into action what all the
smart people are saying we have to do to
save this planet so there's a lot of you
know convening going on
talking about all our problems but
there's nobody out there actually doing
it and that's why we exist is is to
actually find out where we're doing
something wrong and then fix it then
prove to the rest of the world that it's
good business
so bottom will bottom line that's my
bottom line I think that we we don't
have any indicators that are that are
unique to us but it's very we're doing
work now with with other organizations
with a sustainable apparel coalition
that I mentioned and they're coming up
with the indicators that all of our
companies can use and use deeply within
our accounting system so when designers
are making choices about fabric they'll
have that at their fingertips what is it
a you know is it a 49 rating or is it a
64 what what goes on with this
particular textile so four four and four
accounting practices to mean anything
they have to be comparable among
companies so I think the kind of work
that Bob is done in the past and is
going on several other areas will will
generate something that we might use
eventually but there's nothing we're
coming up with individually if I could
just step out of the moderator role for
a second and the answer a little bit
from what I know so one of the
challenges that led to the creation of
the Global Reporting Initiative which is
an international standard was this
confusion about how to measure different
kinds of and forgiving sustainability
performance and people had lots of
different ideas but there is no general
acceptance so one thing now the GRI as
it's known is less commonly used in the
United States but it's used by about
3,000 global companies around the world
and the other thing that I really want
to flag for you it's the thing that I've
been talking up around we spoke about it
at lunch is that there is a movement
right now taking place among some of the
very biggest
standard-setting bodies in the world
accounting called the integrated
international integrated reporting
Council that sounds boring but it's
really not it was pulled together by the
Prince of Wales and it brought together
the International Accounting Standards
Board the Financial Accounting Standards
Board that all of the big four
accounting firms and they are rethinking
the very definition of business I'll
just give you two sentences about that
instead of just thinking of it as taking
financial capital in turning it around
and then having financial results they
are thinking of redefining the value
creation process as drawing multiple
forms of capital in natural social human
intellectual and so forth
churning it around in a unique business
model and then having multiple outcomes
financial social human intellectual
capital now that is about to appear in
an exposure draft or a framework which
believe me the more view that could read
it and comment on it because the United
States is largely silent on this and yet
it could redefine what accounting and
measurement is for firms there's been
some discussion of this for countries
but countries are place-based firms are
not and looking at how this would work
for firms so it's the the the website is
the I I RC org and very important
interesting work different companies
make different uses and I'm not
surprised to hear that Patagonia is
still looking but there is some hopeful
progress being made thank you which
maybe we should take one social media
question yes I have a question from
Halina Torsen who's watching from Norway
how can Patagonia instill the value of
dematerialization into their customers
I'm sorry you can't hear me well I can
sort of hear okay I'll talk louder this
is from Helena Taurus on who's watching
from Norway how can Patagonia instill
the value of dematerialization into
their customers while still selling
their
and growing as a company okay did you
hear that question you know during this
this last recession we've never had such
growth in fact I love recessions we've
always thrived in a recession in a
recession people become very
conservative they don't buy fashion
because that you'll have to throw that
piece away a short period of time and
they'll buy products that last a long
time they'll buy multifunctional
products Newars have become very
conservative consumers and that's the
kind of goods that we make and so we
thrive in a recession when the economy
is great everybody gets silly again and
they start you know buying things that
they want but don't need and we we have
loyal customers we grow what we call
natural growth when the customer tells
us that they just got a catalog and they
ordered 10 things and they got six it
tells us that we're not making enough in
other words we don't prime the pump by
advertising in all of these fashion
magazines and stuff like that art our
advertising budget is less than half of
one percent of sales so we let the
customer tells us how big we should be
and how much we should make and with
this new millennium generation those are
our customers this is the only hopeful
note that I've found going around
speaking and universities and stuff is
that this generation knows what the
problems are and they want to do
something about it
I mean my generation saw Inconvenient
Truth my friends who consider themselves
environmentalist and I say well what'd
you think of that oh that was heavy
well did you change your lightbulbs no
we're not gonna do anything about global
warming we're already way too late
the only hope is with a younger
generation and that's one reason why my
business is doing so well is they
believe in what we're doing I mean green
business is good business do you have
yeah I'm not sure if they cut if the
person from Norway is I'm not sure quite
what the question is but I know we're
asked a lot we took out an ad in The New
York Times on Black Friday last year
saying don't buy this jacket and then
put it on our website on cyber monday
and we got a lot of we got a lot of
response mostly mostly positive but the
the headline was an attention getter and
what the copy' did was to talk about
what the environmental impact of that
particular jacket was and that you
should be conscious and careful when
you're buying things people accused us
of hypocrisy because we are a company
and we do have a marketing department we
have a sales department but I think if
companies don't raise this kind of
question who is and I think it's a
legitimate question for us to raise
we're we're it's also part of an effort
we began about five years ago we take
back for recycling any product at the
end of its life we determined about
halfway through this campaign that we're
we were doing it backwards that really
if you want to address the the mantra of
the four R's of reduce repair reuse
recycle you have to start with reduce
and end up with recycle is the least
important thing you can do and so if we
don't talk about the necessity to reduce
material consumption we're really not
much in line with our values so we have
to do it and we have to take it on the
chops if we're accused of hypocrisy
you've been very patient thank you my
name is Kate I'm at the forestry school
and my question is with a lot of those
responsibilities movement within
corporations we hear about the triple
bottom line how Walmart will reduce
their impact on the environment by
installing a greener fleet of trucks and
then save X million dollars and it's a
win across the board but as far as I
know Walmart just takes those savings
and then builds another Walmart or you
know continues to expand so how do you
make sure that the initiatives that you
take are actually making an absolute
improvement towards the goal of reducing
the environmental impact and not just
doing things less powder or reinvesting
that money and something that's causing
another impact in a different way I
think you can't I think you have to have
a high tolerance for ambiguity so what
Walmart is doing with its trucks is a
good thing and what Wal Mart has done in
the dairy industry to reduce methane
from cows and practices is a good thing
but there is still the question of the
absolute scale of a Walmart there's
still a question about is labor
practices so you know I don't think
there's a I don't think there's a final
answer to that I think you have to kind
of respect what they do on one end and
discourage them from from the other or
make you choice about where you're going
to shop yeah well I'm sorry go ahead I
think I think we ought to ditch the mics
go back to low technology because it's
really hard to understand the questions
up here
yeah actually just yell it out I don't
know what this would do for the taping
of oh yeah maybe a step back a little
bit maybe we can hear you better than
them yeah okay you
yes great my name is Justin Linden mayor
I'm a another joint degree the school
management in school forestry and I
found your comments about size and the
danger of being too big as a real as
something to really take seriously and
so my question is at what point does
Patagonia become too big in terms of
yeah the potential to really adversely
impact the environment and sort of
looking at it from the opposite
perspective one could probably make an
argument that some of you know the
massive multinationals because of their
size have the ability to have a really
dramatic positive impact by just
tweaking you know a small part of their
operations so if you could just comment
on using one size to its advantage
well I wrestled with this question all
the time you know as a climber or
serious whitewater kayaker and you know
doing risk type sports all my life you
never want to exceed your resources if
you're a 5-10 climber you don't solo 511
because then you're dead
and I think society is always pushing
you to exceed your resources and we
constantly question ourselves are we the
size that we should be and we try to
live within that and you know when you
when you learn to ski your growth curve
is not like this that's that's the curve
of a public corporation they have to
grow 15% a year they grow like this when
you learn to ski you go like this and
then you're getting nowhere for a while
you take a lesson you go up a little bit
so it goes in steps and so you know we
grew 30% last year
this year we decided that's too much
we're gonna go to 15% maybe next year
we're only going to grow 3% so we don't
have to follow the dictates of the stock
market and but I think we're at a point
where we're making as much clothes as I
want to make and I'm very pessimistic
about the future so we're diversifying
into food I think you know if there is a
crash for one reason or another if you
know our power grid goes out in America
because some tree fell on a power line
somewhere I mean you know it's
we're so at risk in this society that
any little thing that happens around the
world the stock market crashes and so
but we're gonna have to eat we're not
going to need you know expensive clothes
but we're gonna have to eat so I'm very
interested in and taking a leadership
position and figuring out a better way
of feeding ourselves let's put it that
way and so we're diversifying you know
3m corporation is a huge corporation but
it's made up of I don't know three or
four hundred different companies instead
of one like I was saying about the
United States being too big to govern it
is too bigger and in fact we have a
flawed cosmic Constitution there is an
emerging country in the world that wants
to copy our Constitution or go through
our electoral process oh my god
so anyway I think about this all the
time yes okay this is a question from
Grace Davis who's watching from Santa
Cruz California
what is Patagonia doing to bring all
clothing manufacturing back to the US or
closer to the point of sale there's
there's there we're not bringing back
manufacturing to the United States it
may be that manufacturing eventually
comes back to the United States but
we're still dependent on the complex
chain of textiles and and and in sewing
assembly when we started business we did
about half of our sewing in the United
States because half of the fabrics were
here and about half overseas because
that's where the sportswear was made and
over the years that infrastructure dried
up but it's also moved around the world
it moved from Hong Kong to China to we
now make our most complex garments in
Vietnam and it's moving I think it's
probably got another 10 or 15 years we
do not chase labor ourselves but we're
part of an industry that chases labor
and until that comes to an end I think
we probably won't have manufacturing in
the States and if we do it will be
because we've made some kind of
innovation in in clothing manufacturer
who apparel is one of the oldest
technologies it's dates back to the
Industrial Revolution and it hasn't
radically changed both textile and
sewing so and then the other thing is
there's assumption in the United States
that we're bringing things closer to the
customer but in fact we're some of our
sales are in the United States but we
sell quite a bit in
Japan and Europe and other markets and
the way the in some of our in Vietnam
and in China there is a lot of
clustering of the textile mills around
the manufacturing that's actually very
efficient it just doesn't happen in the
state so I think if we brought our
manufacturing back to the stage would
become martyrs
would go out of business I mean look at
American Apparel which is one of the few
companies still making everything and in
LA and there are on the verge of
bankruptcy they I mean I don't want to I
don't want to go for martyrdom I don't
make a very good martyr and it's I'd say
really good sewing takes an incredible
amount of skill it takes people who
devote their whole life and sewing and
our most technical products are all done
in Asia by excellent workers in
factories that you can eat off the floor
it's we could never do that in this
country again we have problems the
factories that we use in Vietnam China
and Mexico have daycare some factories
give house loans to people who want to
buy houses and the conditions actually
for the factories that we have left in
the United States we do use a number of
people who make t-shirts we really have
to monitor those conditions more closely
than we do with our Asian factories
because the conditions are worse the pay
is worse and the benefits are less yes
hi my name is Marvin and I'm with the
School of Management I'm just wondering
as an accomplished Mountaineer and a
surfer and a fisherman some lessons that
you've learned that you've brought to
business leadership I think you kind of
touched on it a little bit your answer
to one of the previous questions but
it's wondering if there are any things
from kind of your life as a Mountaineer
and stuff that
you've brought into this weather your
lessons from that your life is a
mountaineer effect the way you do
business well I've been a student of Zen
philosophy most of my life and I've
learned a lot about you know climbing
and not focusing on the end goal but
focusing on the process the reason I
don't care to hear about whether we're
what our profit is going to be this year
all I care about is that if the process
is going well we're going to be
profitable and that's a big lesson I
learned in in climbing and also I
learned that what is sometimes seemingly
a risk is not a risk like for instance I
tell you a little story
I had I used to do a lot of kayaking a
lot of whitewater kayaking and and I
learned the hard way there were no
kayaking schools my first trip with my
dirtbag buddies I my first river was a
class three my second the next day was
the class for the next day was a class
five and I ended up a two-week trip with
fifteen stitches in my face but I had to
learn on my own but the day I really
learned to kayak was a day I ran a
little local River in Jackson Hole
that's a class four in high water and I
ran it in the high water and I ran it
without a paddle I just got a wild hare
I had learned to do a roll with a hint
my hands so I did this thing without a
paddle which seems really stupid but
what it did is it taught me that I had
to turn the boat by putting on his edge
and carving instead of just doing a
sweet stroke at the last second and
avoiding a rock I had to look way ahead
when I went over a drop I had to make
sure I didn't end up like this
and I had to anticipate it and go
forward anyway I learned to kayak that
day and I did a perfect run of this is a
river that falls a hundred feet a mile
and and it's just no Eddie's and it's
just a big flush I did a perfect run I
went down like a fish well what seemed
to be a high-risk thing actually was the
best thing I've ever done because then I
went on to do first descents all over
the world and all over South America and
New Guinea and River dangerous rivers
and I've never hurt myself so by taking
a small risk you avoid the big risk
that's what I think doing these kind of
sports has taught me and it's the same
thing in business we take these risks
that a public corporation would say man
I think out there we're not out there at
all it's it's the fun part of businesses
is breaking the rules and making them
work I'm wondering if you'd like to tell
us at this point and we'll of course
keep going with the questions but about
the responsible company project that you
are pulling together and getting ready
to launch yeah we people who are
familiar with our catalog know that we
run an environmental campaign for about
a year and a half to two years at a time
and my last campaign has been called our
common waters and is focused on on fresh
water scarcity and pollution and the
dangers to it our next campaign which
will start and fall thirteen will talk
about will be called the responsible
economy and we'll talk about some of the
questions we raised here about how you
can have prosperity decoupled from
ongoing increases in material use and
it's I think it's very much in the air
I've been around I've been in back east
for a couple of weeks talking to
different colleges I think it it's a
it's a topic that everybody wants to
address but hasn't been addressed
publicly I think people are ready
to talk about it and we'll be the first
company to do so and this is I think one
of the things that would look like a big
risk for for a public company but will
look like a small risk for us when did
you say it would start a fall third fall
2013 okay yes sir thank you my name is
Aaron I'm another joint degree student
at the School of Forestry in the School
of Management and at the management
school we talk a lot about corporate
culture and how that's attracts talent
just furthers workplace productivity and
any number of the other intangibles and
your first book you talk a lot about the
working environment at Patagonia so I
was wondering if you could comment on
how workplace culture can help further
your environmental goals well certainly
it comes from the top I mean you know my
wife and I are both committed pessimists
yeah we're doom bats we believe that
there's no difference between pessimists
that says oh it's all over don't bother
doing anything and an optimist that says
oh everything's gonna be fine don't
bother doing anything I'm a pessimist
that wants to sleep at night so I I want
to be feel like I'm part of the solution
rather than part of the problem and we
corporate culture the most important
person in a company is the gatekeeper
you can change your company by who you
hire overnight let me tell you and we've
made some bad hires because of that you
know like I said we give money to
Planned Parenthood and I've had people
in the company say you know I'm really
opposed to this and I tell them you know
you shouldn't be working for a cup
where you believe they're doing the
wrong thing just the way it is you
should go work for a company that you
know believes in the values that you do
and so we're very careful in who we hire
for every job opening we have at
Patagonia we have an average of 900
applications we just hired a corporate
attorney from Levi's who is leaving a
very high-level high-paying position to
come work for us because she wants to do
more than be at a corporate attorney and
it's it's self-replicating if you have
all your employees feeling like they're
working for more than just a paycheck
and they're actually part of the
solution to the world's problems you
don't get anybody that cheats at work
you don't get anybody that takes
advantage of our work policy like you
know we have this policy of let my
people go surfing which means I don't
care when you work where you work as
long as the job gets done
that's all I care about I've only had
one instance where I feel like anybody
took advantage of that and my wife was
at the hairdresser and here one of the
guys was having it as getting a $40 a
haircut in the middle of the day
that's the only time they've ever taken
an advantage of that policy but it it's
you know it starts with not having
special parking places for management
when I go into our cafeteria I paid just
like everybody else I don't get a free
lunch
and so that sends a message to the whole
company this is the way it should be we
are entering the last 15 minutes or so
and I'm going to keep going I want to
make a couple of quick announcements
about opportunities that I hope you will
consider because there's so many things
we've all have said that we sense this
and I'm sorry if this sounds a little
bit like an advertisement but it's also
an opportunity last year there was a
student led conference at Harvard
University on the new economy and we
supported that with a relatively small
grant of $5,000 and some advice about
who you might want to and they might
want to invite and so forth we just
received another much larger grant for
almost $200,000 to support eight more
student-led conferences on the new
economy and we are going to be
announcing that and hiring a conference
coordinator but if this is a topic that
really interests you given all of the
wonderful interconnections that already
exist at Yale
we would love to entertain an
application from whatever assortment of
student groups that might want to do
this
our ultimate goal and is to hold a
hundred student conferences in 2013-2014
in order to help stimulate this
discussion and a real rethinking by
faculty by alumni by administrators and
of course by students themselves both
undergraduates and graduates so that's a
something the other thing that I want to
mention to you which how many of you
heard Bill McKibben when he came
relatively recently okay so you know
Bill is getting geared up for a major
debate about fossil fuel after the
election
and he believes that the time has come
to for institutions to start shedding
their fossil fuel stock I asked him what
he thought the connection was between
the new economy and the fossil fuel
campaign and he said in a very pithy way
as he does he said the new economy will
flourish when we get to the old fossil
fuel economy's dead weight off our backs
and so there is a connection between the
frustrations and difficulties that we've
experienced in fossil fuel which is a
very complex topic and the opportunities
that exist in the new economy so I want
to make you aware that these are just
it's a time a very rapid change we're
lucky to have the kind of leaders that
we're hearing today but there's so much
more going on and you can play a key
role in that now I'm going to come back
I think it is your turn and as I say we
have about 15 more minutes thank you all
for being here today
I know New Haven's not quite as nice as
been Tura so thank you for being here
but I my name is Heather West I'm a
another joint degree with the School of
Management in the School of Forestry and
actually wanted to build off of Aaron's
questions I feel like we've talked a lot
about intone internal culture and
thinking about you know what are the the
operations within your company and
within the greater network of folks
looking at cotton looking at water use
but I know that Patagonia has taken a
stand on a number of very outward
advocacy facing issues with damnation
coming out in a couple months I think
and I was just kind of wondering what
your your thoughts are on private
companies taking a more advocacy role in
environment issues but issues that face
the country at large is there a line who
should be you know where it where's that
line do you think I guess I can I can
tell you a little story I hope I
understood your question I think I'm
losing my hearing or something
there's a there's an echo for those of
us sitting in here I I gave a talk at a
so called sustainable fisheries
conference in Vancouver a couple years
ago and I talked about what we're doing
with our supply chain we're asking
questions and finding out what we're
doing and then doing something about the
bad things that we're doing that and I
then I challenged all these fish
distributors and fishermen in this room
I said you don't know where your fish
comes from I said I know a lot about
salmon because I'm a fisherman they
happened to know that if you catch a
sockeye salmon at the mouth of the
Columbia it could be one of ten that
makes it all the way to Idaho to redfish
lake to spawn and now there's only nine
if you're catching pink salmon you're
also having an incidental catch of chum
salmon which is an endangered species
you have to dump them overboard dead and
if you're catching a coho salmon it
could come from a river that has a pulp
mill and it's full of dioxins and it you
shouldn't really be selling that feeding
that to people well that went over like
a big thud and so I walked away from
that and then I said look you need to
know because your customer is going to
demand it when they go into a restaurant
a lot of restaurants are telling you the
name of the farmer who grew the chicken
or grew the lettuce or the name of the
chicken in the name of the chicken in
Portland they have the name of the job
so I was I walked away from that
conference thinking huh that was a waste
of time they're not going to change
their practices and stuff so then we I
said look I said to myself well you know
the only way to lead is by example so we
started our own salmon processing plant
80 miles from the ocean on the banks of
the skeena River in British Columbia and
we employ the local natives to fish in
the old way with fish wheels and fish
nets and fish traps and and Beach
sayings they catch the fish alive
they released the steelhead on the coho
which are unintended catch they keep
only the sockeye or the pink
whichever one we're looking for they
killed them and bleed them right away
which means the bled salmon will keep in
your refrigerator for 20-something days
as opposed to six or eight days with one
that's not bled and of course none of
them are bled when they catch them in
the ocean because they just dumped them
in at all anyway so the reason we're
doing this thing is to prove to the
fishing industry this is the way it
should be done and this is the way it
used to be done sustainably the Indians
along these rivers knew exactly how many
salmon did take and when you catch them
and then it became illegal to catch him
in there was always because the white
men wanted to catch him out in the ocean
with their diesel-powered boats
so like I said the only way to lead us
is by example and that's one of the
things I want to do with this food
business is is create change by doing it
ourselves you know you know we talked
about these students getting together
and trying to figure out the next
economy the government's not going to
figure it out and in fact it's up to us
I mean we're we're citizens but we're
also according to the government we're
consumers that's what the government
labels us we're not citizens anymore
we're consumers and that you look under
the word consumer in Webster's it's one
who uses up who destroys that's who we
are stock market goes up and down
according to how confident we are and
but if you look at any newspaper on a
daily basis you'll see that all the
gains made in society are made by
citizen activists civil democracy is the
strongest force in society
we have to regain that and we can do it
you know not by giving up being
consumers but by being better consumers
educating ourselves as to what we're
buying and and using that force to
change society and I think all of us
want to do the right thing is just that
we're not we we need to educate
ourselves as to what we're doing most of
the damage caused to the planet is done
unintentionally there's unintended
consequences of everything that we do
and we have to anticipate that we have
to get back to the well anyway so we
this event was organized largely by the
Divinity School we have the Dean of the
Divinity School the Yale Divinity School
Advisory Board many members we haven't
had a chance to talk about that very
much I'm wondering whether you have some
particular observations or advice for
what a significant community like Yale
Divinity School could be doing to play
its part in this conversation well I
just read your article on growth I
thought that was fantastic and you you
challenged the school to all religions
have to consider what we are doing to
the planet right now right now you know
it's doomsday we have their growth of
doomsday religions all over the world
there's people giving up living on this
planet and living for the next life you
know living for those 72 virgins that
are waiting for us and this is it this
is the planet that we have we're not
going to colonize Mars and we better
take care of it and I think there's
quite a few religions that are and
religious leaders that are understand
but quite a few that are not still I
think there's also from what I I'm not
religious
so but what I've what little I've seen
is that I think religion is still
concentrated on private life and on kind
of Sunday morning on the opportunity to
step out of daily life and reflect on it
when in fact what we really need to do
is go back to this question of being
citizens what are we as moral beings
that has to be at the heart of religious
life and also what are we as producers
you talk about the passivity of
considering yourself a consumer we've
almost lost the sense of ourselves as as
productive people as people who and our
working lives are actually responsible
for what happens and that is where we
have much more responsibility what we do
at work has much more responsibility
creates much more effect than what
whether we recycle our our paper at home
and I think religion needs to take that
up Christianity is far more about what
what daily life is about and what we do
on a daily basis and how we treat people
and treat the earth than it is about
just reflection on a Sunday morning well
I think yeah it's leading that examine
life whether it's whether it's business
or anything else know what you're doing
know the effect of your actions are I
had a chance to meet Michelle right
before the this talk so I'm very
interested in your question so my name
is Michelle Lewis and I'm a joint degree
student at the School of Forestry in the
Divinity School and I've been looking at
ways to connect underserved populations
primarily low income communities to the
environment and how religion can be used
to help do that and the thing that I've
come up with repeatedly in my research
about the lack of engagement to the
resource
lack of access or accessibility issues
which bring up issues of environmental
and social justice and so I'm wondering
what your company is doing who you're
partnering with to address issues of
access amongst underserved populations
in the United States we don't have much
involvement in where we have where where
people are sewing and making the goods
we are currently engaged in a program
with Fair Labor Association to both
create a living wage make that a
standard and also to bring about the
ideals of the fair trade movement which
takes some of the profit that ordinarily
goes to the factory owner and takes it
back into the community so that the
workers actually decide what is done
with those with those money I think
that's a you know that that's about as
much as I know about what we're doing
there so we are almost out of time
but I'm going to ask if we're going to
do two more questions and I'm going to
ask a very brief final question if you
could keep your questions quite brief
Yale class of o7 undergrad my parents
owned a ski shop in my town and I grew
up helping them self attic onea products
which I've always loved and been
galvanized by the story and the
narrative behind it and I'm passionate
about helping people connect their
values where their purchasing behaviors
that said one of the challenges that we
face is that in our store patagonia
products are pretty premium there are a
very high price and they're kind of seen
as for a niche consumer and my question
is within the current economic
structure of our society where there are
externalities of cost is it possible for
companies who adhere to the checklist
the back of your book for example to
sell their products to more mainstream
consumers at a price point which seems
more competitive to them well I mean in
in the stores that we sell to like your
store we're the same prices North Face
or the same prices Marmot we're the same
prices all our competitors there's not
that much difference I would never want
to lower our quality standards to be
able to sell to less wealthy people I
mean it's just I tell you know the poor
can't afford cheap goods can or cannot
they cannot afford cheap goods instead
of buying a blender at Costco for 1995
that as soon as you put some ice in
there and it blows the motor out then
you got to buy another one we have to
get into the attitude of okay I'm gonna
buy a blender that's gonna last the rest
of my life I'm gonna save up until I can
afford it
till I can pay cash for it and that's
going to be it and I mean that's the way
I run my life I've never bought anything
on time I I mean I've had a mortgage
yeah but that's about it I wait till you
know I've always waited
I mean I'm coming from a background of
eating cat food when I was a young
climber and I gave a talk at Walmart one
time to all the buyers at Walmart and
they warned me at Walmart that said look
make sure you get across the 1200 buyers
from Walmart get across to them that
pedigree is able to do all of these
things not because you're selling to
wealthy expensive things that wealthy
people you
get it so you relate to everybody here
because your average Walmart customer
gnarling has no credit card he has no
checking account comes in with their
welfare checks so I gave a story I said
look you may think you know that were
successful because we still expensive
products to rich people but that's part
of it but also sell to the dirt bag
climber or skier or whatever who lives
out of his van and they save up and when
they do buy a jacket they buy ours
because it'll last a long long time
it'll be multifunctional it'll do what
they expect it to do and that's a big
part of our customers and when they go
into a Walmart store to buy their cat
food like I used to
I didn't buy at Walmart I used to buy
from dented cat food
I mean dented cans store buy cases a cat
food so when he goes to buy his cat food
at Walmart and the cat food is made in
China and it's full of melamine you're
poisoning my customer so what kind of
value are you giving to your customer
yes having connections with like-minded
companies I'd like to just circle back
to the beef corporation concept which
you brought up but then I think got kind
of lost in the shuffle Patagonia is a
beef corporation has that been something
that you consider significant to your
company do you think that's a
significant trend or does it merely
reinforce what certain companies would
do anyway and I say this in the context
that now it's becoming a legal entity in
certain states I mean to be brief a beet
Corp is a benefit Corp and it's like
you're a farmer and you put your land in
a conservation easement or a farming
land trust
that assures that your farm will never
be developed and it'll stay in
agriculture forever and that's what
we've done by signing up as a B Corp
we've stated what our values are and you
can't change those values without a
hundred percent agreement from the
owners and the stockholders so it takes
a lot of pressure off of us because the
system in America forces you to become a
public company if if I wasn't a B Corp
and died my wife and I died our the
stock is held in a trust and stock goes
to an environmental foundation that we
started according to the law the
foundation can only hold 20% of any one
company stock so they would have to
divest 80% of the stock and to be a
responsible foundation you'd have to
sell it to the highest for the highest
value which is to go public you can
imagine what we could get for if we went
public as a company because we were one
of the most reason I mean would make
more money than Krispy Kremes did which
sold for 40 times earnings then crashed
of course so this allows us to our
future heirs or whatever to continue the
business with the same values it puts in
stone the same values that we operate
now and they wouldn't have to sell to
the highest bidder they would have to
say they could sell to private investors
who believe in the same things that we
do and want to maintain the same values
so it's been a this B Corp is is super
important for us but I think you know if
the government really enforced the laws
of corporations there's a lot of
corporations in America that would lose
their charter and that's never happened
all right well and wrapping up I want to
point out that we are in a very
interesting time when to draw on a
Divinity School tradition we now see
certain extraordinary business leaders
emerging as prophetic voices really
raising fundamentally different visions
for the future and that's a very
valuable thing I want to report to those
of you here that a member of my team up
in Boston said that the online chat is
currently trending evolve for president
so no sorry short too short to be
President
short people don't become president so I
that my final question to you is you are
talking about companies but I wonder
about this institution you say when
you're talking about in your chapter
where to from here I'm interested in
both of your responses you say we
advocate a combination of steady
improvements with the occasionally
breathtakingly bold move to keep
everyone awake and motivated to show
leadership that reflects well on
everyone so my question since we're here
is what would be a breathtakingly bold
move for Yale University well if it was
a few years ago I would have said
recycle you know I mean a few years ago
the last institutions to really get it
or hospitals who serves the most
unhealthy food in the world hospitals
right in Japan you get out of a major
operation then they feed you sashimi we
feed you know lime jell-o and the last
ones to discover recycling we're
universities and that's really simple I
mean change the light bulbs I don't know
if these are LED bulbs or not but they
should be it's very simple just look
around and go through the checklist
wait I went through the checklist for my
own company and I came up to about 70
percent we're doing about 70 percent
well there are all kinds of things I
think one thing if if yell is having a
discussion about the the new economy or
the next economy it would be what would
be the investment strategy of its
portfolio I mean you already see that
it's already addressed a lot of
questions about how it behaves in the
community but that would be a made that
would be a major question for the
university I think I think I was offered
a fellowship here at Yale now I've got a
degree in auto mechanics from John
Berlin high school but what they saw is
the school of Forestry and environmental
studies was teaching all these courses
in environmental studies and the School
of Business was teaching business
courses but neither one was teaching the
business school was not teaching
anything about the responsibility to the
planet I gave a talk at Stanford a few
years ago and to a bunch of grad
students industrial designers industrial
engineering and when I told them to
include environmental considerations in
their designs they said no teacher had
ever told her told him to do that that
was about six or seven years ago there
was a total disconnect between business
and environmental responsibility or the
school of Forestry was cranking out
students who were going to go and work
for an environmental organization with
no training and business and they were
gonna go up against you know teams of
corporate attorneys with money from a
bake sale so the idea of combine you had
to is what we're trying to do at
Patagonia I just want to thank Dean
Stirling I want to thank all of you I
want to thank the Yale Divinity School
advisory board that's been and I
especially want to thank
president shoe narc and standing for
what I think has been an extremely
illuminating conversation and I hope
it's the first of many I know that
you're going to continue to travel
around and talk about this and I hope
that we will have more conversations
here at Yale and I hope that the people
who are watching online will stimulate
because I think we are as you say so
eloquently we are at a moment where we
both must and can start rethinking these
basic questions and I want to thank you
on all of our behalf for taking
leadership in action and then expressing
it in this beautiful book so thank you
very much thank you